enough about self-defense learn
self-offense
strike hard strike fast no mercy are you
worthy enough to become a cobra kai yes
sensei we're going to the cast of
netflix's cobra kai for all their worst
and best moments onset injuries and
nasty drink takes weren't strong enough
to take them down
let's do this you ready
let's be good
number one this on-screen smooch was
certainly a least favorite highlight of
mary mouser in sholom mariduena's time
in the dojo oh god i i really messed up
miguel and samantha's kiss may have
seemed natural and called for to us but
the real kicker is that right before the
camera started rolling mauser told sholo
that he was like a brother to her that
is quite possibly the worst thing you
could have said we'll just say that she
may have started a string of unlucky
on-screen kisses because when she kissed
tanner buchanan later on she apparently
passed on to ravi a dreaded cashew
allergy which unfortunately opened up a
whole new aspect about himself that he
didn't know about i'm also allergic to a
lot more things that i was not allergic
to before
number two hardcore johnny lawrence the
cobra kai sensei himself was not a
stranger to hardcore injuries on set we
do not allow weakness in this dojo actor
william zapko was taking the hits during
a fight versus the legendary sensei john
crease when things started off on the
wrong foot as zapka sparred his toes
somehow got lodged into his foot we just
have one question for his toe are you in
oh yeah
he was in horrible pain from the injury
but like a true cobra guy he popped it
back in and refused to give up the fight
all right i want to really pop
make a chrome
number three so we know that you all are
die-hard fans of the show but you might
not know that ralph macchio was about to
film the nastiest thing
this is where i almost lost to fear
season four episode two would have
brought us a stomach twisting scene
showing daniel larusso chugging a not so
appetizing shake he resisted at first
but brought himself to do the nasty act
disappointingly it was out of the final
product crazy that is definitely the
word for it number four it was too hot
for the characters to train sho2geko or
so it seemed you guys want to cool off
the scene was set to shoot on what would
appear to be a hot day but scheduling
forced production to settle on a very
cold day it's real uncomfortable cast
members had to sell the weather so they
were dressed in hot temperature attire
and even sprayed with water to make
sweat could have told us to bring our
swimsuits and to make matters even more
confusing the following scene had the
ensemble in a freezer but now it's
switcheroo time now they can relax in
the heat this heat is brutal okay so
which one is it sam
number five it's payback time baby for
chosen that is now let us see how much
you really know this moment is brought
to you by a thing called stretching
which yugi akamoto probably should have
done before filming
old age means you have to be careful
about the stress you put on your body
high kicks and fast punches can be very
risky okamoto forgot to realize this and
pulled his hamstring
[Music]
number six we're jumping back to the
weather and this time there's no hot
freezer to save the day
hop in
thinking of having to film on a cold day
don't shoot it in the water but that was
not the case for mauser and buchanan who
had to film the scene in ice cold water
oh it's cold
and once tanner pulled himself together
to jump in he missed this line i
actually tensed up and then by the time
i got there like you need to say
something that's cool we guess we're not
yet done with this one oh jeepers on top
of the cold they were bombarded with a
literal hurricane it was just one of
those things you'd have to be there to
see it unfortunately the actors were
given no relief to the nightmare come on
guys get back up that was great number
seven looks like this is just one of
many injuries mary mouser sustained on
set luckily she got away with her face
intact on this one
they sure
in this particular scene we find
samantha and robbie joining daniel for a
serious conversation but things only get
worse for sam no no this is part of the
process yeah the process on top of the
almost broken face mauser was attacked
by bugs not those pesky little flies but
angry little yellow jackets
number eight zap gundamachio reunited
with some old friends and boy does it
feel good
and where'd all that time go
they got to visit some old campsites and
bars from the original films we're lucky
we got some added bonuses as well as
some cool fight scenes with chosen and
john crease and some throwback bonding
with tommy
both zapka and machio felt great to have
them back and loved every scene they had
with them we'll have to wait and see if
we get a huge battle of the legends
wonder who will throw the first punch
they strike first
we'll pre-strike okay number nine so
this is one of the cast's most memorable
scenes they got to throw punches at
school
it was so confusing for a scene of this
size it took them four days to prepare
with how detail-oriented show creators
wanted it it proved to be a tough couple
takes we wish we could say no one was
hurt in the process but guess who that's
right mouser gets it again
now this was a wild day for me and
peyton with all the kicks and punches
flying around on set it has to be hard
to block every single one but it's
always that one kick that lands someone
in the er i got knocked in the hand i
misplaced my hand to absorb a kick poor
mouser had to go to the hospital over a
block gone wrong in trying to emulate
her mentors she came back the very next
day to finish the scene my hand is taped
and you can actually if you pause it you
can see certain shots or my fingers are
like taped together number 10 there's no
limit as to how far these characters
will go to prove a point even if it
means getting rough and fancy attire
there's a brawl fisticuff a squabble all
it took was story saying one not so nice
thing to sam and we all know she won't
back down from a fight that first kick
from mauser was actually more dynamic
than it looks we did a lot on the fly
this day crew wanted to make sure they
could sell the kick from the right angle
so it took a few kicks for them to call
it hope she stretched those hammies but
hey the injuries were kept at a minimum
and by minimum we mean yet another
injury for mouser this time a thumb one
she just can't get a break can she i was
supposed to like actually like have a
hold of my wrist during this scene we
see them brawling it out by the pool
side and mouser clutching robbie's hand
in a very strange way give me your house
my wrist like this and i'm like oh he
looks injured number 11 food fight not
the one you think but definitely the one
we wanted to see from our favorite
karate students
all right let's see what you got glad to
see all the hard work that sam and
robbie put in on the balance board paid
off what a scene to remember and
certainly one that many of the stunt
doubles would like to forget
12 we're ending things off on a good
injury-free note
i could eat
we get a small piece of nostalgia when
daniel takes johnny to his old home and
even johnny is excited about it he never
got to visit in the original films he
had other johnny-like things to do i
wasn't in that part of the movie i was a
defense fight what a ride it's been
watching our childhood heroes pass down
their karate wisdom those moments of
anguish and pain were enlightened by
some great moments of the cast to cobra
kai
never accept defeat surely we can expect
more to come from our favorite karate
kids
did you have a favorite on screen moment
leave a comment below